kanye west enjoys a night out with his
son saint after being banned by
instagram i'm just extremely happy can
you tell by my face
on wednesday the 44 year old rapper was
suspended from posting on the social
media platform for 24 hours following a
series of posts that metta the parent
company of instagram deemed a violation
of its policies on hate speech
harassment and bullying the meta-imposed
insta-ban came after the grammy winner
launched a series of online attacks at
his estranged wife kim kardashian her
boyfriend pete davidson comedian d l
hughley and daily show host trevor noah
i see a woman who wants to live her life
without being harassed
by an ex-boyfriend or an ex-husband or
an ex anything yay fired off a racial
slur-filled rant against the 38-year-old
tv host after trevor shared his thoughts
on the former couple's split on his show
tuesday you may not feel sorry for kim
you know because she's rich and famous
but
what she's going through is terrifying
to watch and it shines a spotlight
on what so many women go through when
they choose to leave of course many of
the rapper's posts have been aimed at
the 41 year old kkw beauty founder who
kanye claims is preventing him from
seeing his children god please
you know there's no reason why these
young children
upon their father's request
shouldn't
be allowed to come to
sunday service
at this point it's it's going too far
earlier this week kanye posted this snap
of his eight-year-old daughter north's
backpack to instagram that's a pin of
him kim and an alien and he wrote in the
caption this was on my daughter's
backpack when i was allowed to see her
last week this is why i go so hard for
my family i am wired to protect my
family at all costs
shortly after that kim who has seemingly
tried to keep their issues private
clapped back in the comments quote
please stop with this narrative you were
just here this morning picking up the
kids for school i'm just rolling with it
and
it is what it is but shortly after kanye
was temporarily banned from instagram he
was all smiles for boys night out check
out yay and his six-year-old son saint
in san francisco at the golden state
warriors versus the boston celtics game
that's the daddy-son duo twinning in
matching black rain boots dark jeans
black hoodies and black leather jackets
where the two sat courtside sharing
snacks and talking as they watch the
game an eyewitness tells et saint was
especially pumped about meeting celtic
star jaylen brown just do something for
my heart of course kim filed for divorce
after six years of marriage back in
february 2021 and asked for joint legal
and physical custody of their four
children north saint chicago and psalm a
source told et at the time that the
rapper was fine with the joint custody
agreement and the two were committed to
co-parenting together but earlier this
week a source told et that yay feels
like he hasn't been getting enough time
with his little ones and if his lawyer
can't work something out with kim he'll
go to court
[Music]
you